a minute and two goddamn seconds of King
logos Comcast someone who went to high
school roughly at the same time this
flashback opening is taking place in
this is the nicest cool boys locker room
in the history of 20 years ago schools
movie thinks asses aren't physically
funny also there's no way somebody this
unpopular dances around school showers
like this especially not at the
beginning of the school day when any
asshole can walk in in a soldier's ah be
rid of showers you're in first period
bully keeps tabs on Robbie showering
habits please it right there can I get
an arrow on that sign yeah that one in
the back left that is literally the
worst pep rally sign ever geez first my
lovin you're never going to get it and
now unbelievable they said this was 20
years ago the beginning of this thing
both of those songs are from the early
90s and not 1996 where we'd be hearing
more Macarena and come on right at the
train hell I'd even settle for some
ironic if you got it sorry no student
body anywhere loves a popular student
this universally it's called high school
everyone hates each other the bullies
said that Bob always showers during
first period as if everyone in the
school was in first period at the time
and not at an assembly and what kind of
assembly takes place around the time of
first period instead of at the end of
the day also how terrible is a principal
that these bullies think they can just
drag someone from the showers into the
gym naked and expect no reprisals for it
what bullies would get this hands-on
with a fat naked guy they hate and how
far does a naked guy slide on gym floor
like zero right everybody here finds
this hilarious when you'd probably get
three nervous chuckles tops and the rest
of the assembly would just be in an
uproar this couldn't be less funny well
the pig's blood and Carey was probably
funnier than this and it only got a
couple bit chica Faust well there's no
coming back from that I guess we should
find this terrible principal who doesn't
give it all arias because of his doesn't
give it yes but considering the cruelty
of the gag it plays like they're
laughing at sanctioned abuse yeah seems
right the guy who won all those
accolades and was a star athlete and
academic is in a dead-end job in an
office story why shouldn't that mean he
was a dick at the beginning of the movie
the guy was super nice and smart and
athletic I mean this dude couldn't cash
that in hey check it it is apparently
required in comedies these days for the
character to work at an office where he
shares space with some smarmy asshole
senior o'houlihan I guess that's funny
he can go to lunch with coworkers
because he was taking a
way to lunch but somehow they were going
to the same restaurant so he gets the
whiff it yeah okay in my life down here
became a disappointment that's wrong be
this guy in the movie says has been with
this girl for 20 years describes his
life as a disappointment then act
surprised when she gets angry this is a
movie husband a real world husband knows
better than this
Calvin react to this is if he hears the
movie sound effects thinks it's totally
weird that the phone rang right after he
clicked confirm instead of not noticing
anything weird like everyone else
uh-huh black people don't go therapy go
to barber shops that's when we talk on a
problem we watched a movie barbershop
sure let's just reinforce stereotypes
about race for all the funnies watching
pop things people don't ever say when
running into somebody on the sidewalk
comedic overreaction is such an
overreaction it forgets the comedic part
it's 60m and there in the eastern time
zone so there's no way there's a
football game on unless this bar are
showing reruns because the NFL never
plays games that start at 6 p.m. Eastern
you know Mike Herculean survival or road
block or the Scorpion King just one okay
Bobby's in a while remember this this
was the very jab did no music exist in
1996 this movie revolves completely
around early 90s hits as if the music
industry declared a freeze on new music
after 1992 blow away he ate sir somebody
actually said yes someone was now dammit
look I don't doubt these assholes exist
but this is bull a dude that is this
ridiculously rude just in time to get
his ass kicked by the rock is what I
call a convenient asshole just letting
everyone know this is over a stolen
chair at a bar it's not the conflict we
wanted but apparently need it you like
Jason Bourne amber would George
hilariously that sense was literally the
pitch for American ultra hey I got an
idea
let's roll here's my bike there were
absolutely zero helmets in the vicinity
but when they drive off Bob not only got
one on but he's got a spare for Calvin
also both of these men are forgetting
the beers and shot this guy just drank
and I thought high school was going to
be like like sixteen Candles you'll see
that movie on blacks on
this is the second time black people
don't do that it's supposed to be funny
and I'm gonna count it I just thought I
was meant for more you know guy doesn't
see that marrying the most beautiful
woman ever isn't a great life cliche I
don't know I just did it man exactly
so do it now Bob once Calvin to do the
backflip he used to do in high school
and if this doesn't end up being a
hilariously painful situation I'll
remove five sins otherwise I'm going to
add five angle I man wait a minute is
this movie telling me that Calvin is an
expert hacker who can get into this
illegal offshore account site or is the
movie telling you that Bob gave him the
password and Calvin is the type of guy
who would say bingo and then after an
ordinary password entry because either
way it's simply hour and 47 minute movie
about a CIA guy goes the first 30
minutes not CIA and feeling more like
Romy and Michele's Grosse Pointe blank
hey sex with a jet jet those are
obviously hilariously undersized for Bob
but they would also have to be
ridiculously oversized for Calvin to fit
it so I'm calling bull on your sight gag
movie I can't believe I'm having a
sleepover at Calvin Jordan's house right
oh I'm surprised as a couch hide-a-bed
made that can tolerate the rocks weight
and frame without bending or collapsing
I'm being serious TBS pretty much plays
exclusively syndicated sitcoms on
weekday morning so this coincidental
Sixteen Candles airing the morning after
bob said he loved this movie is some
bull
yeah whatever movie he cleaned up
everything and put that bed back up and
change you know what I'm just going to
stick with you yeah whatever movie he
had any contact with this man the CIA is
only here because they know for a fact
bob was talking to Calvin or trace that
computer hack here or any number of
things the CIA could know so why are
they bothering with a simple knock I
don't why don't they have other CIA
people around the house to make sure Bob
can't escape come off I'm pressing the
timeout but it's the button that you
press when you're overacting and you
need to cheat laughs let's see some
today
oh this apparently hasn't ever happened
to this dude at work before scare well
everything agent goes toward the stairs
leaving the entire floor open my
favorite as long as mops in the building
no one's safe that's why we brought
three whole agents to track and bounce
definitely isn't behind the door here
but is suddenly behind the door here
Plus where is he hiding to make a phone
call and be in the office at the same
time suddenly there are three other
agents I don't know where because even
the movie realized how stupid sending
just three agents with this guy was yeah
hang tight everyone Kevin Hart's going
to give the play-by-play of what's
happening in this scene you know for
hilari
holy where were these guys I guess they
were in the middle of their customary
smoke break also all of the
guys miss the CIA conveniently doesn't
have anybody directly behind Bob which
means that's where he's escaping and
three two one I guarantee you it's
impossible to know the exact number of
seconds the next I will take to burn up
to the sprinkler also and perhaps more
importantly that sprinkler system is
perfect since it should have gone off
almost as soon as the tie fire started
and shouldn't have dated actual flames
to reach it before going on also also
that tie took four minutes to burn all
the way up to the top also also also
somehow the CIA is ported by water
luckily the standoff occurred right in
the spot where these two could jump out
of a window and directly onto the
inflatable gorilla outside also despite
having 437 agents on the top floor
nobody's down here just in case Bob
escape all these gunshots and none hit
Bob or Calvin or the tires hey what's
this honey okay guys this is where I
check out of the movie in character was
never funny now he's making me go search
for the manager of this theater and
demand double refund passes and I need
your super sweet accounting skills why
even if you've had to go rogue to catch
the real bad guy how does a badass agent
like you not have any contacts around
the world with accounting skills bob's
murdered partner is being played by
aaron paul which almost certainly means
he was not murdered and he's the actual
bad guy also enough does this murder get
pinned on Bob oh yeah Bob murdered his
partner with a stick him in the elevator
and blow him up technique classic
motorcycle guy is storm trooper terrible
of aiming Jesus toddler with an Uzi
would be more accurate than this Curt
also how does this guy know they're here
okay maybe the GPS but didn't bob
disconnected
and if he disconnected it why did he
think it was a good idea to stay here
when this is the first place the CIA
might look if they ever figured out what
GPS to look for instead of just shooting
Bob right now this guy would rather do a
bunch of motorcycle karate on him
guaranteeing he will not succeed no no
don't go home oh okay so you're not
going home right I spend so much time
asking his wife not to go home shocked
she doesn't go straight home I swear to
god 23 percent of this movie is Kevin
Hart making faces and noises and unfun
aliy riffing Kevin Hart is now the male
Melissa McCarthy really funny person
that gets less funny the more the
director allows him to riff okay I am
scared okay I don't have motion in my
system if I say it down on told it
nothing's coming out farts are just air
I'm confused
should I hope that mr. Hart got paid a
lot of money to say these lines or
should I hope he didn't get paid a lot
of money to say this lines either way
somebody got robbed
test with a ghost figment of his
imagination he started calling the black
badger interesting since 20 seconds
later agent Pamela says this Bob stone
is the black badger how could the black
badger be made up real at the same time
he killed him to cover his tracks
Jesus you figured that out in three
weeks a you conducted an investigation
that led you to believe Bob did this
even though there are way easier methods
to kill a guy and make it look like an
accident you're the only one Bob trusts
through some reason how you babe Calvin
this is dr. Dan even more total nonsense
because now even if Calvin told his wife
about Bob sleeping downstairs and she
was okay with it now I'm supposed to
believe that she saw him downstairs this
morning and didn't make a connection
when it turned out their therapist was
the same guy how could you hit your wife
this whole therapy session made it into
the movie somehow it could have made the
decision not to have it in there but
somebody decided to keep it
and only a certified international
banking official can accent its Trevor
you moving your bolts on because you
want to know what they're gonna vote on
homecoming king and queen again maybe
you'll Maggie can make it two for two by
the way these guys have a ten-year high
school reunion that's the one most
people go to right could they forget
that the Oscar goes to
clever oh wait he was cooking with them
if the rock doesn't break this guy's
fine before the scene is over I'm gonna
be offended once if that kid always at
that kid if that were the case then Bob
would have trouble beating up bullies no
matter what because they would remind
him of the pain from high school but
because it actually happens to be Trevor
of all people he suddenly freezes up
unnecessarily sidetracking this movie
and meaning Trevor's ass beating will
have to occur at the Reunion because
that's how these movies do Suzy tries to
have heart after a full hour of the
exact opposite of heart even though
technically it's been at least 60% heart
not is so affected by the old bully
reviving the high school bully memories
he leaves Calvin behind even though he
needs Calvin to mathematical brain to
complete his mission thanks for sharing
I mean if it's undisclosed do I really
benefit from learning that look at the
torture room got it location is
unimportant control if you want to
stomach for even though why'd you even
let this tool into the interrogation
chamber in the first place he's a pawn
you used to get to Bob you don't need
him and he hasn't earned any right to
watch interrogation he can
when agent Harris says you can leave
that's why I'm leaving you in the Sun
locker room with no guards who among us
hasn't seen a banana and instant we
decided to escape this works also
bananas traction I really am sorry this
clock in the background says it's 441 I
really am because the clock in the next
room says it's 741 I really didn't want
to notice this or give it a sin but
there it is so Bob and Calvin try to be
best buds again just outside the
interrogation room and not only do they
have time for that way once again
somehow managed to get in a situation
where the three main agents are the only
agents until they've action demands more
give you a dollar if you can decipher
what the fuck is going on in this action
sequence Calvin don't learn by osmosis
or something to be able to do that nope
you can't toss a guy ten feet into
concrete and have this kind of wall
exploding reaction concision the first
what this is gonna hurt Wow Calvin had
that one-liner timed out perfectly
somehow those agents don't know that and
don't shoot at the tires look at this
vibrate on that whoa what look if you're
gonna steal the pulp fiction line do it
right don't put a dull in front of jet
you made it weird
like a chocolate Google fake chocolate
Google that's not only Google racist but
delicious sounding dude all you got to
do is plug those digits into the GPS and
boom so why did you need a super sweet
accounting brain then if it's just plug
in numbers and boom couldn't you've done
this yourself you ever still playing
before does this question even need
asking yeah he answers with some
hilarious starburst thieving story but
no he has not stolen plane before you
jackass second largest penis hunt in
history what was the largest penis hunt
in state history Fassbender Emsworth Oh
art not Korean so you better believe it
took a long time in fact I'm just gonna
let Kumail take this you're stereotyping
Korean dicks that's racist yeah and I'm
adding 50 Cent's Plus Kumail Nanjiani
would be amazing at citizen mod and
Calvin are able to take off from this
runway without anyone noticing and
apparently don't show up on military
radar on the Atlantic coast Plus
completely out of gas I know for a fact
this is bull before I even get to the
part where they show that Bob is faking
this whole thing that's how movies like
these are the setup is too obvious
you're wasting our time well these feels
a scene from San Andreas because let's
be honest who the remembers anything
about that movie I like it you attention
make bird call oh oh man I got a hand up
to Kevin Hart he's actually blasting
through these horrible audience
pandering scenarios with full force and
no embarrassment fun
I can't make bird noises I never could
that's your biggest weakness not fear of
heights or addiction or daddy issues and
the rock is getting off an elevator with
a gun and you can't tell what movie or
film franchise it's from that's a sign
the film you're watching is a beautiful
hilarious and while I understand this is
a comedy if Bob had told Calvin
basically anything along the way this
wouldn't seem like such a random finale
do it
go ahead I won't you want to bet Harris
is not the Blackmagic American a mistake
aa sudden there Oh Who am I kidding I'm
not surprised like anything in this
movie I am the black batcher you may not
have heard it but Calvin apparently
recognizes that Aaron Paul is Phil how
the does Calvin know that did he see a
picture of him all he's heard is a story
Bob told it and another story agent
Harris told I am the black batcher
no I'm the black badger I really don't
give it through the black banner in so
long as we can end it soon when this
thing's over I'm going to rip your
throat out my Patrick Swayze Roadhouse
movie continues it's out of date
references for the benefit of someone
also Roadhouse sucks there I said it the
CIA once again brings three people also
three CIA bitches appear and fire guns
and even though the bad guys had like 25
men on their side this will somehow
devolve into an even battle Calvin
Joyner went to the previous school of
running away from things instead of ever
turning Calvin counted on the
uncountable SUV X marketer to save his
ass thank heavens Bob somehow timed this
don't seriously believe this guy do I
get behind me jet movie tries to make me
doubt the rock is the good guy at the
last minute which isn't gonna work
because this moves towards the rock duh
nobody hits nothing here normal everyday
foot and fist fight requires an edit for
every blow landed also fight
choreography brought to you by who gives
up since the camerawork is so shaky nice
no that's at this point I'm just waiting
for this to turn into anchorman 3 and we
suddenly see the Terminator Bart Simpson
Dirty Harry Michael Corleone and
everyone else who's ever had a thing
show up on screen Andrew the face well
know why your pal Bob could never been
the black badger it's because he's too
riche villain overexposed it's and
creates a window for the hero you know
faking my own death was the easy part
Jesus stop talking I mean seriously what
is the point this is so insulting I'm
getting away with a half a billion
dollars boy scout bob is going to spend
his life in prison so I guess it makes
sense that Bob would fall for this but
anyone else in the CIA - with a Blood
Pact like this show up is not your blood
at all but ink or someone else's blood
the and this was your plan you actually
thought Bob would get framed for this
calendar as you do a backflip and it
looks faker than the Twilight baby thank
you thank you for the location text it
completely and totally makes this movies
ending so war no kidding you are an
eagle screenwriter soar on the breeze
you are what makes me special
everything to me mags I love you
absolutely nothing in this movie showed
that he learned this marriage lesson he
literally went through some bogus eih
and now suddenly cares about his wife in
his marriage out of the blue how does
Bob Stone win homecoming king I have to
the votes on the fight in how the is
something as silly as a 20-year
highschool reunion homecoming cane
election on a computer wouldn't you vote
for that when you actually got to the
reunion and usually paper ballots and
wouldn't the thought nobody knows who
bob stone is kind of derail this whole
thing Robbie may be good how can someone
have this much of a bully boner for real
like legitimately I don't even feel
great that Bob finally punches this guy
it's like thirty eight-year-old people
where's the boy in that twenty years ago
in this gym I stood in front of you all
naked and embarrassed movie is trying
way too hard to have a feel good morally
positive ending and it's lame as shock
yeah sad to say but the funniest thing
in this movie is that guy celebrating
catching Bob's pants you fell II don't
remember Darla
Looby is trying to kamikaze all the
happy endings that can fit into the last
five minutes believe you remember me
remember you how could I forget you I
know because I'm glad everyone's
enjoying his dance performance but did
he ever put on any Underpants
I mean is he still hanging out there
like the swing ride at a County Fair so
now that she's pregnant are we supposed
to believe that for 20 years this was
never a problem for Milly feels like
this couple we've gotten divorced about
15 years ago if that were the case as I
close this movie is still going even
though it ended 10 minutes ago well I
sleep in it most nights no you don't
that was bad intelligence very bad
intelligence I'm sorry
[Applause]
this is my own private domicile and I
will not be harassed bitch you know how
filled I'd give bouncing at the
blackmagic killed she was Keizer salsa I
am the black batcher
no I'm the black batcher I'm Spartacus
I'm bata got today I took my first crap
in two weeks hey if you can't be adults
and give these candidates the courtesy
they deserve then you don't deserve to
be called adults by children because
that's what children are and you'll be
treated like children you don't know
about them because if they were to come
into use they put the oil companies out
of business
the concept of the internal combustion
engine has been obsolete for over 50
years but because of the oil cartels and
corrupt government regulation we in the
rest of the world is forced to use
gasoline for over 100 years